this isn't like confidential stuff but
you
sitting on a porch looking over the
world looking at the work that andre is
doing
that elon's doing with tesla autopilot
uh do you like the trajectory of where
things are going
well they're making serious progress i
like the videos of people
driving the beta stuff like it's taking
some pretty complicated intersections
and all that but it's
it's still an intervention for drive i
mean i i have autopilot the current
autopilot my my tesla i use it every day
do you have full self-driving beta or no
no so you like where this is going
they're making progress it's taking
longer than anybody thought
you know what my wonder was
is you know hardware three is it enough
computing
off by two off by five off by ten off by
a hundred
yeah and and i i thought it probably
wasn't enough
but they're doing pretty well with it
now yeah and one thing is
the data set gets bigger the training
gets better and then there's this
interesting thing
is you sort of train and build an
arbitrary size network that solves the
problem
and then you refactor the network down
to the thing that you can afford
to ship right so the the goal isn't to
build the network that fits in the phone
it's to build something that actually
works
and then then how do you make that most
effective on the hardware you have
and they seem to be doing that much
better than a couple years ago
you